so uh representative yoho of florida a
few days ago got into a bit of a heated
exchange with representative alexandria
quezo cortez
outside of the um capitol building in
washington and in this exchange yoho was
mad at cortez for specifically for some
of the stuff she's been saying about the
rioting and chaos and the violence
and how she tried to claim that all this
is happening because people just want
bread for their families
and um he said riojo said to cortez
you're out of your freaking mind
um which you know you can see why he
would
think that and then she called him rude
and
as they left parted ways joho said of
cortes
but i don't think to her but said it
sort of under his breath as he walked
away
effing b word only he didn't say
ethic b word he said the words
themselves that was overheard by a
reporter so you may not believe it but
we should note that yoho was asked about
it and his response was no comment
and then the guy he was walking with
another lawmaker
was asked what happened and here's here
was his response he said
i was actually thinking as i was walking
down the stairs i was thinking about
some issues i've got in my district that
need to get done
i don't know what their topic was
there's always a topic isn't there
that's a good that's a good friend folks
that's uh he ain't snitching
um i just love that his excuse is that
he didn't hear the argument because he
was just so
immersed in thinking about his district
and wanting to help the the folks back
home
um you know totally believable of course
great stuff there
now this is all a setup to tell you
about
the only part of this that concerns
anyone really
cortez decided to spend time on the
floor of the house
pandemic going on chaos in the street
country
in turmoil she decides to waste
taxpayers time
on the house floor complaining about the
mean words that someone said to her
uh here she is i walked back out
and there were reporters in the front of
the capitol
and in front of reporters representative
yoho called me
and i quote
these are the words that representative
yoho
levied against a congresswoman
the congresswoman that not only
represents new york's 14th congressional
district
but every congresswoman and every woman
in this country
because all of us have had to deal with
this
in some form some way some shape
at some point in our lives this issue
is not about one incident it is
cultural it is a culture of lack of
impunity
of accepting of violence and violent
language
against women an entire structure of
power
that supports that and that went on for
almost 10 minutes
get over it he said a bad word this
isn't 9 11 okay it's not a national
tragedy we don't need your 10 minute
speech about someone saying something
mean to you
this doesn't concern anyone but the two
people involved
no one else cares why should anyone else
care what possible relevance is it
you guys got into an argument he called
you a bad word okay uh you know
sorry i what do you want
and no yoho was not using abusive
language towards women you know she's
trying to turn this into an attack
it's not an attack on all women he
wasn't abusing he wasn't using abusive
language towards
towards women he was using abusive
language towards one particular woman it
was an attack
on one it was a personal attack on one
particular individual it was not an
attack on all women everywhere
a personal attack and that's relevant
because
personal attack means deal with it on
your own time
deal with it on your personal time go
talk to him and tell him that you hurt
your feelings
that's fine it's it's not something that
everyone needs to hear about
i mean this this whole thing that we get
especially from liberal women
anytime they're insulted or attacked
this is an assault on all women
everywhere
no it's not he just doesn't like you i'm
not defending what he said
not saying it was the right thing to say
but this concerns you and him
you're not a representative for all
women everywhere
in fact i'm guessing that well over half
the women in the country
or at least half uh would would say that
you don't quite represent them or their
values i i i feel pretty safe
saying that there are millions of women
in this country who do not consider
alexandria queso cortez to be a
representative of them
and then and then of course you know she
she during this soliloquy she uh
proceeds to act as though you know
this this never happens to men you know
this this happens to women far too often
we get
yeah okay you know men get insulted too
all the time okay men get called
sexually degrading names also um
and you know it's even actually more
acceptable in society to do that so
it really happens to everybody not a
huge deal
deal with it on your own time thank you
for tuning in to the daily wire one of
the fastest growing conservative media
outlets in the entire country if you
enjoyed this video
uh be sure to give it a like and a
subscribe to our youtube channel so you
don't miss out on any of our content